The last model of motivation that we're going to discuss was developed by
Abraham Maslow. Maslow developed the model of motivation in which he termed the
Hierarchy of needs. This Hierarchy of needs states that we progress or move
onto higher needs once the more basic needs are relatively well satisfied.
Otherwise, we stay concerned with the more basic level needs. Here. Look at
this model. For example, if we're dying of hunger, we're not concerned with
beauty or aesthetics. But only with getting food. At the most basic level of
needs, we need to fill our physiological needs. These are the things such as
the need for food, water, oxygen. Or even an adequate body temperature. These
are our basic needs in order to survive. And once we have our physiological
needs met we can move on to the next level of the pyramid and that's a need for
safety and security. Safety needs are things such as having security,
protection, stability and also not being exposed to things such as terrorism or
fighting. On the third level. Is our need for love and belongingness. According
to Maslow, the third level includes things such as our desire to belong to our
family or belong to our social groups. We'll discuss the need for belonging in
more detail a little later on in the lesson. The next level is our self-esteem
needs. And this is the need to appreciate ourselves and our worth. Here, we
want to be appreciated and respected by others. Finally, at the top of the
Hierarchy of needs is self-actualization, or the inherent drive to realize
one's full potential or one's abilities in life. But because this is at the top
of the hierarchy, it's harder to achieve because all of our other needs need to
be satisfies first.